morocco bladepoint is a 60 player action
battle royale game with a variety of
melee and ranged weapons along with
abilities and unique movement options
there's definitely a lot to explore but
if you want to get a quick look before
you jump in then stay tuned to the rest
of the video we're going to be covering
naraka a lot more here on game spot so
if you enjoy what you see today then
leave us a like and subscribe so that
you can stay up to date
my first place
[Music]
[Music]
the hungry
our armor is whole again
the moment online
my wounds are sealed
the hungry thing the grave is
[Music]
is
[Music]
yet
my weapon is restored
[Music]
why do they challenge me
never ends wealth
[Music]
[Music]
not yet
one shadow
[Music]
my weapon is restored
now it may perform its function again
the shadow spreads
[Music]
huh
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
filth
our armor is whole again
[Music]
my injuries afflict me no longer
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
yet
i shall
[Music]
[Music]
our foes approach
[Music]
the shadow will shortly begin to spread
[Music]
[Music]
the shadow thickens
[Music]
join the fray and now up your pay
you have to join me in this fight we
will attack our enemies
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our phones approach
[Music]
[Music]
this is not yet
sterling equipment devoid of curses or
demons
a pleasant fluke
now lovely weapon
instead of rust you shall be in blood
oh
[Music]
[Music]
huh
is
i am out of school
[Music]
is ready to unsheathe
behold the wages of defense
[Music]
you